[Music]
so last week sit down with Brigitte
Gabriel received quite possibly the most
positive reaction that we've ever had to
an interview
I'd say that well over 90 percent of the
responses that I saw on YouTube Twitter
and Facebook were appreciative of our
discussion of her incredible story
growing up in Lebanon during the Civil
War about the roots of radical Islam and
what living in a free society is really
all about people were in awe of
Brigitte's personal story amazed by her
passion impressed by her candor or some
combination thereof if you haven't seen
her episode yet but you only have a few
minutes check out the last five minutes
of our chat to see what a true love of
Liberty and freedom is all about we'll
put the link to that right here in the
description below oh and for the record
I wasn't tearing up because of her
impassioned speech it was because of
these damn bright lights they were
getting to my retinas you know how it
can be I mention the reaction to our
interview with Brigitte because it
reiterates a lesson that I've
consistently learned while doing this
show before we had Brigitte on I talked
to my team about whether we should have
her on at all after all Brigitte is
hated by a lot of people who call her
the usual buzzwords like racist bigot
far-right extremists and so on while we
all know that the people who are using
these words are becoming the new boy who
cried wolf and that these words
themselves are losing their meaning by
the minute the chill effect these words
have still remains in certain quarters
even in my case when I'm selecting my
guests I do have to think for a moment
if there is going to be some sort of
cost for me to sit down with someone I
still get a ton of hate for talking to
my lowly innopolis my externa [ __ ]
Tommy Robinson Paul Joseph Watson and a
couple other people in none of those
cases none of those cases do I regret
having the conversations regardless of
the blowback these interviews may have
caused me but it does bring to light an
important topic it's not just those who
are being targeted as bigots and racists
who are in the firing line of those who
would like to silence us it's also the
people willing to talk to those people
and hear them out this guilt by
association is incredibly dangerous
because it can bite any of us for having
a family member or even a friendship
with someone who shares political views
that fall out of the mainstream
should we disown people with use
different than ours
should we defame them should we publicly
humiliate them all of these are small
steps towards reporting them to the
authorities the wrong thing we should
also note that in the online world
there's an information battle constantly
happening when you put Bridget's name in
Google the first site that comes up
which isn't one that directly affiliated
to her is Islamophobia dot org which is
part of care the Council on
american-islamic relations now think
back to my interview with Brigitte for
just a second what was the bigoted part
after living through everything she has
does she strike you as the problem in
society does she strike you as a bigot
or racist or a right-wing nut I don't
think so what I think is most
interesting about the assault on
conversation is how recent this
phenomenon is my friend and mentor Larry
King has built his legendary career on
talking to people from every walk of
life and from every part of the world on
five days of any giving week he could
talk to a member of the Ku Klux Klan
then Louis Farrakhan than the cast of
friends then Magic Johnson and then the
Pope nobody ever accused Larry of
sharing all their beliefs just because
he talked to all of them actually this
very concept would have been seen as
totally ludicrous I'm proud to say that
I know Larry pretty well and it's his
curious mind and real sense of wonder
that made and still make him want to
talk to all sorts of people doing all
sorts of different things as you know
it's my policy that sunlight is the best
disinfectant that people with bad ideas
will eventually hang themselves if given
the room to do so and I consistently try
to do that this growing sense of guilt
by association is just the next level of
what the regressive left has built it's
not enough just to label someone a bigot
anymore now we have to tar and feather
them so that other people will be afraid
to talk to them as well and if you're
willing to talk to someone outside of
their accepted group Vultar and feather
you to in an effort to shut down any
furthering of conversation and yes
unfortunately
I do see this phenomenon far more on the
Left than on the right these days it's
almost as if when you cut through the
hysteria and the screaming and the
slandering that they don't even believe
their own ideas in the first place so
they don't want counter ideas heard but
they also want to make sure people
aren't entertaining other ideas in the
first place
this is incredibly dangerous and it's
not a game that I'll be taking part in
we can't give them an inch because they
will keep taking and taking until
there's nothing of us left between this
silencing of those who veer from the
mainstream and the YouTube be
monetization that I discussed last week
those of us who really are fighting for
free speech have our work cut out for us
and I am up for the challenge by the way
fortunately we're continuing our
partnership with learn Liberty this week
and joining me is assistant professor of
economics at the University of Tampa
abby hall abby is also an affiliated
scholar at the Mercatus institute and a
research fellow with the independent
institute a nonpartisan educational
think-tank we're going to talk economics
war and peace the drug war our
militarized police and much more I'll
gladly accept my guilt by association to
her and we'll see how it goes as to
whether she can say the same about me
[Music]
you
[Music]